you know what's funny is i was just on
the phone with tom welling who was uh
clark kent on smallville for years with
me who
i've never who well it's funny because i
told him i know him well i told him
i told him that i'm interviewing you and
he goes i like that guy goes but i i
gotta tell you i i never thought i mean
i never think he likes me i don't think
brandon likes me he said that i go do
you want me to tell him that he goes
yeah i just i don't think he i don't i
don't know what it is but i i don't know
i'm not sure if he likes me or not
no
oh i don't like that um uh no i do i
actually do i really like tom in the in
the well i'm sad that he feels that way
but now he can feel hopefully
um better about that no tell listen he
listens to all of them
uh that's what he tells you
i'm telling you he questions me about he
goes you should have hammered him so and
so more on that
no i i i i i appreciate and i enjoy our
time together when we've been to uh
several concerts together especially the
last one we did in england um
uh he's got great he's got he's very
charismatic
uh and i like his energy and uh no i i
like the dude i look forward to spending
uh more time more time with him we had
an interesting first uh meeting
tell me about it
and i and i never asked him about this
so we're we're like sending we're doing
this through you good this is good do it
through our first our first meeting was
i just got in the role of superman
and superman returns
and
had never met him before and we're at
nike nike used to do this thing maybe
they still do where you go and
if you're you know you get a whole bunch
of free nike stuff right
um and um
he was he was
scheduled to come
after me
down this building down in marina del
rey in california it's like oh well hang
out and say hi i'd like to meet him i
never met him before not even thinking
like what he might be thinking all i
knew is that maybe he didn't want to do
that he didn't want to play superman
anymore i didn't know for sure
but anyway we went down
and he's he's he gets out i think he's a
truck and i'm there with courtney
and i and uh
and uh the the
very kind woman from nike tracy
introduces us i say hey how you going
how you doing
for me i was like he doesn't like me
it was very it was a very short two
shots they're very short they're like
hey hey how you doing yeah yeah uh yeah
superman ah cool okay uh see you later
and that was it
really that was it no congratulations no
nothing just kind of maybe he did maybe
he did all i remember was i thought he
didn't like me because then i became
because then i realized oh maybe i
shouldn't have maybe he didn't want to
say hi to me because he was having you
know mixed feelings about it right no
matter what he's played clark kent for
his whole life um
and pretty much pretty much and uh
you know i'm kind of forcing this
meeting so maybe i'm like the bat and
you know maybe just like
and then and then finally i met him
again
at a years year and years later at one
of the conventions like three years ago
maybe it was the first one we did
together in um
and uh oklahoma right it could have been
oklahoma or something anywhere somewhere
anywhere
and he was
nice and cordial and and uh
and it erased that
you know that feeling because he
embraced he embraced me and didn't seem
like he had a problem and
um i have to look on the fact that he
didn't think that i embraced him but no
i maybe there's that young female like
well he you look tom he likes you
welling brandon likes you brandon tom
likes you that's just the way it is but
maybe there's something to be said about
you're both young
you just got the biggest part of your
life he just got the biggest part of his
life maybe there's an ego maybe
inadvertently it just feels like you
don't know how to act around each other
we all grow up years later you meet a
convention it's all like that now we've
done it what's up dude got it i'm an
adult now you're an adult because you
know people think you know what do you
think of jesse eisenberg what do you
think of so-and-so i'm like hey
congratulations to him i'm thrilled for
him that he got you know lex luthor and
uh
but look is there
people will also say
do you get jealous do you get upset i'm
like
i don't get jealous about someone
getting a part
i get upset more resentful about not
being considered or auditioning or given
the opportunity to prove myself or so
that's the only thing i'll say but never
with an actor you can't i can't get
upset for someone they cast as lex
luthor you know what i mean
totally